-Today is Friday. That's usually
when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was just running a bit --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
-I was running a bit behind
today so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that cool with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
Come on, man, yeah!
-J-James, can I get some
thank-you note writing --
You have to say it.
-Yeah!
-Alright, there you go, yeah.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you,
"Thor: Love and Thunder" poster
for looking like how I feel when
I find my other AirPod.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you to the poster.
-Hmm.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-It's going off the rails.
♪♪
-Thank you, CNN+, shutting down
after 3 weeks.
I guess if I want somewhere to
get my news 24 hours a day,
I'll just have to watch CNN.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you, airplanes,
for immediately replacing
the dangers of COVID with
the dangers of Mike Tyson.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ouch.
♪♪
-Thank you, Coachella, for
looking like a Forever21
just took an edible.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you,
Netflix possibly launching
an ad-supported streaming plan,
though it's a little harder
to Netflix and chill
to the Stanley Steamer jingle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What is that again?
-♪ 1-800-STEAMER ♪
-Both: ♪ Stanley Steamer
makes carpets cleaner ♪
-Yep.
I like --
-You like Rug Doctor.
-♪ 1-800 and 588-2300 ♪
-Both: ♪ Empire ♪
-That's a -- That's fantastic.
-I like, uh --
-I don't even know what they do,
but I want it.
-Yeah, you just want it.
[ Laughter ]
-Any jingles? Favorite jingles?
-It's too local, though.
-Which one?
-Do you remember --
We had a show called "Ideal"
in the Tri-State Area.
-"Ideal?"
-♪ If you got a passion
for fashion ♪
♪ If you got a cravings
for savings ♪
♪ Take the wheel
of your automobile ♪
♪ And swing on down to
"Ideal" ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's pretty good.
I don't know that one.
I like it. I like that one.
That's good.
[ Laughs ] ♪ Ideal ♪
♪♪
-Thank you, 4/20, for being
the second time this week
people were convinced they saw
a giant bunny in a vest.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He's got a vest on, man.
♪♪
-Thank you, wedding rehearsals,
for saying,
"Take a good look because here's
what your wedding
would look like if everyone
wasn't wasted."
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, pomegranates,
for being a great snack
for people with 6 hours to kill.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, surprise parties,
for officially confirming
that all of your friends have
a group chat without you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You lied to me.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Thank you, people that say
there's plenty of fish
in the sea after a breakup,
for basically saying,
"So, maybe humans
aren't for you?"
There you have it, everybody.
Those were my thank-you notes.